[Música]
los incendios en Canadá no sólo están
afectando la salud de millones de
personas en Estados Unidos y también en
el territorio canadiense sino que los
extremos climáticos dejan también un
impacto en el medio ambiente para hablar
de esto nos acompaña desde Houston Texas
Antonieta Cádiz directora ejecutiva
adjunta de Power en acción Antonieta
Gracias por estar con nosotros empecemos
por una pregunta básica Cómo se explica
esta temporada tan prematura de
incendios en Canadá y que a pesar de que
todavía no son los tiempos más calurosos
se estima que sí pueden ser los
incendios más devastadores que ha vivido
este país
Bueno un gusto estar con ustedes María
Clara se explica por el cambio climático
esa es la razón Ese es el paraguas con
el cual nos estamos moviendo actualmente
partamos por algo bien básico los gases
de efecto invernadero se acumulan en
nuestra atmósfera calientan nuestro
planeta este calentamiento a un fenómeno
que llamamos calentamiento global ha
cambiado nuestro clima eso implica que
ahora tenemos fenómenos de clima extremo
muchísimo más frecuente entonces acá en
Estados Unidos estamos cada verano cada
vez que comienza el verano vemos olas de
calor extremo cada vez cada verano se
rompen nuevos récords de calor lo mismo
con la sequía sequía extrema sobre todo
en el área del Oeste Estados Unidos
hemos visto fenómenos de sequía extrema
que han generado problemas como como por
ejemplo que se ha agotado el agua en
ciertos estados y hay cortes de luz
programados como por ejemplo en el
estado de nevado California precisamente
por la falta de agua también vemos
huracanes de rápida intensificación yo
te estoy hablando desde Houston Texas en
el año 2017
vivimos el huracán Harvey por ejemplo
que inundó toda la zona donde desde
donde yo te estoy hablando fue un
huracán masivo de Gran intensidad Y eso
se ha hecho más frecuente lo mismo con
las inundaciones lo mismo con los bordes
costeros estamos viendo cómo ha cambiado
nuestro clima y eso es a raíz por
supuesto del cambio climático entonces
fenómenos como los incendios climáticos
se han hecho cada vez primero más
frecuentes y segundo más extensos
entonces vemos como sobre todo ahora
está ocurriendo en Canadá pero acá en
Estados Unidos por ejemplo en el área
oeste del país cada verano tenemos que
prepararnos para los incendios
climáticos porque sabemos que vienen
sobre todo en el área de California
sobre todo en el área de Oregón Nevada
en la costa oeste justo usted Menciona
los incendios en la costa oeste y el año
pasado Estados Unidos vivió una de las
peores tempora das de incendios
forestales de su historia ahora qué se
puede esperar teniendo en cuenta que
todavía no llega el verano en el
hemisferio norte y aún así estamos
viendo lo que está pasando en Canadá
Lamentablemente están es nuestra nueva
realidad y me gustaría darte un poquito
de esperanza y decirte que que este
verano va a ser un un buen verano para
todos nosotros pero lamentablemente lo
que tenemos que hacer es prepararnos
para el verano Y es justamente lo que
hacen legisladores acá en Estados Unidos
comunidades de base vecindarios
gobiernos locales todos estamos
esperando los impactos del verano esa es
la razón no sé si te fijaste por ejemplo
que hay compañías de seguro ya en
Estados Unidos que están diciendo que no
van a poder cubrir ciertas áreas ciertos
estados del país porque están demasiado
expuestos al clima extremo Entonces esto
básicamente es una nueva realidad con la
cual recién estamos aprendiendo a vivir
Yo te diría acá en Estados Unidos y en
todo el mundo y hay antecedentes de que
un incendio o cientos de incendios como
es el caso de Canadá ocurran en un país
pero el humo contaminante se trasladen y
crucen las fronteras el conjunto de Ver
imágenes como las que hemos visto en
Washington y Nueva York Sí por supuesto
que lo es y y yo ahora que estaba viendo
las imágenes de Nueva York no podía
evitar recordar las imágenes del veinte
todos estábamos enfocados en la pandemia
pero ahí también recordemos que teníamos
los Cielos anaranjados en en California
acá en Estados Unidos justo fue un año
en la campaña presidencial donde
justamente tuvimos un presidente a un
candidato en ese tiempo Joe biden que
habló de la crisis climática como la
crisis de Esta generación y se desató
justamente a raíz de esos incendios
climáticos ahora usted nos decía que
quisiera tener un mensaje esperanzador
de que este verano no será peor pero que
la ciencia muestra que los extremos
climáticos son cada vez más frecuentes y
más prolongados aún así le quiero hacer
la pregunta de qué se puede hacer para
evitar estos impactos por ejemplo Canadá
luego de que se quemaran más de tres
millones de hectáreas de su territorio
el Primer Ministro Justin trudeo lanzó
un plan de emergencia estas medidas
funcionan y nosotros desde casa qué
podemos hacer
funcionan absolutamente Yo te diría que
algo muy importante destacar acá es que
gracias a que hemos visto los impactos
del clima extremo es que las personas
los líderes políticos líderes
comunitarios todo el mundo está
reaccionando hasta esta crisis todo el
mundo que está conectado con con las
personas que representan y acá por
ejemplo en Estados Unidos el año pasado
se pasó una ley climática histórica que
fue la ley para reducir la inflación
esta legislación implica una expansión
tremenda de la energía limpia que
justamente lo que necesitamos para
frenar el cambio climático para frenar
el calentamiento global necesitamos
frenar nuestra dependencia de los
combustibles fósiles Antonio tanola
quiero dejar ir sin antes preguntarle ya
habíamos hablado de los efectos de estos
incendios en la salud humana pero Cuáles
son las consecuencias en los ecosistemas
y en la biodiversidad
Lamentablemente estos incendios
climáticos arrasan con todo y como tú lo
estás viendo en las imágenes esto
evidentemente el humo como explicaba
Marta nos afecta a nivel de salud sobre
todas las poblaciones que estamos más
expuestas decir que vivimos expuestos a
contaminación diariamente producto de
las operaciones de gas y petróleo
Entonces nos ponen mayor riesgo Pero por
otro lado también los incendios
destruyen toda la biodiversidad a su
alrededor y es muy difícil reconstruirla
pasan décadas para que uno pueda
restaurar para que uno pueda recuperar
esa biodiversidad por lo tanto Este es
un problema que nos afecta a nivel de de
ciudades a nivel de vecindarios Pero por
supuesto también es un tremendo impacto
para nuestro planeta Antonieta Cádiz
directora ejecutiva adjunta de claymath
Power en acción Gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí gracias por la invitación